il
[Musique]
une ville qui bouge beaucoup on a
peut-être des règles
enfin on voit pas trop les règles codes
de la route d'être comme ça parce que
tout est un peu n'importe comment on a
fait un premier dix journées à katmandou
et je trouve que ça ressemble un peu à
la cuisine que je mange à la maison
c'est bien épicée ses forces sur canal
[Musique]
où
il
je trouve
très bouleversant de parce que bah on a
un côté très fort on va être mais c'est
très beau c'est un c'est vraiment
magnifique et les petits drapeaux je me
rappelle comment ça s'appelle mais les
petits drapeaux et puis les gens en
général sont ils sont très gentils et
c'est un premier observant la ville
magnifique même si elle a pas forcément
les moyens de l'être selon les critères
[Musique]
ça me dans un temps un temple sacré et
autour de moi il y a
à dessein des petits singes les gens
viennent ici pour pour demander des
grâces pour prier pour leurs familles
et là comme en ce moment on est en
plaques au vide que tout ça s'arrête il
ya la guerre que tout s'arrête et voilà
pour la prospérité
[Musique]
totalement différent de la réunion gars
qu'on va on va en europe ou bien c'est
une autre culture une autre manière de
vivre genre ben moi je trouve ça trop
mais en fait ça permet de découvrir de
nouvelles nouvelles choses et tout et
voilà c'est que tu puisses
[Musique]
il